>> Will Sentance: Hãy xem, giải pháp 3,
từ khóa tự động hóa công việc khó, mới.
Lợi ích, nhanh hơn để viết, tôi nhận được nó.
Nhìn toàn màu xanh, đó không phải là chúng ta đang viết nữa.
Thường vẫn được sử dụng một cách chuyên nghiệp.
Và một phần lớn của nó là, nhưng chúng ta sẽ thấy, giải pháp 4 thay đổi nó một chút.
Vấn đề là 95% các nhà phát triển không biết nó hoạt động như thế nào.
Tôi nghĩ do đó, phỏng vấn thất bại, có một động lực nhẹ nhàng để học hỏi,
và do đó không thể gỡ lỗi và tạo mã sạch và đáng tin cậy mọi lúc.
Đây là một vấn đề nhỏ khác với nó, đây là thiết kế,
Tôi có thể nói, dòng chảy không phải dòng chảy, đó là một động thái thiết kế không thông minh.
Người dùng đó tạo một hàm nếu tôi chạy nó mà không có từ khóa mới,
Tôi tìm thấy nó trong cơ sở mã.
Và khi tôi đang điều hành nhóm của mình và tôi bắt đầu chạy mà không có từ khóa mới.
Điều này sẽ kết thúc mà tôi đề cập đến sáu thứ gì trong đối tượng?
Nó sẽ chỉ gì cho Braden?
>> Braydon: Toàn cầu.
>> Will Sentance: Đối tượng toàn cục, được biết là rất tuyệt vời, nhưng
bạn có thể nói, tốt, rõ ràng là tôi cần phải có từ khóa mới, phải không?
Vì vậy, chúng tôi sẽ nhận được điều này quá sớm.
Nó không giống như vậy bởi vì tôi có thể có mã khác trước đó mà cái này thậm chí còn ở đó.
Tôi có thể thích một hàm được khai báo rằng tôi đang sử dụng nó,
rằng điều này có thể nằm bên trong hàm mà giá trị này bằng.
Vấn đề là tôi không biết khi tôi nhìn vào chức năng đó rằng nó yêu cầu một
từ khóa để thực hiện công việc của nó.
Đó có lẽ không phải là quyết định thiết kế thông minh nhất, phải không?
Bạn có thể có xu hướng muốn có thể nhìn vào chức năng và đi,
Tôi biết rằng điều đó đòi hỏi một từ khóa mới để làm bất cứ điều gì hữu ích.
Vì vậy, các nhà phát triển đã giúp đỡ lẫn nhau.
Nếu bạn có thể tưởng tượng ngôn ngữ mà nếu nó sẽ là một hàm
yêu cầu đó là sẽ tự động hóa mọi thứ, bạn sẽ không khai báo nó với hàm bạn
khai báo nó với và hàm tạo là một thuật ngữ điển hình cho
bất cứ thứ gì tạo ra sẽ xây dựng một đối tượng.
Nhưng JavaScript đã không làm điều đó.
Họ nói rằng không có vấn đề gì là các chức năng, hãy để nó như một chức năng bình thường.
Và sau đó chèn trước ba chữ cái mới khi bạn chạy hàm.
Tôi không biết.
Điều đó không lý tưởng cho
các thành viên trong nhóm của bạn giống như nếu bạn viết nhận xét để nói với họ nhưng.
Vậy trong thời gian ngắn, các nhà phát triển đã làm gì để giúp đỡ nhau
mà họ biết khi họ thấy một hàm rằng nó cần một từ khóa mới trong
trước nó để làm công việc của nó?
Ừ, tiến lên đi Adam.
>> Adam: Viết hoa.
>> Câu Di chúc: Viết hoa chữ cái đầu tiên.
Và đó là lý do tại sao bạn sẽ không thấy, bất cứ khi nào bạn thấy một từ khóa mới được sử dụng trước
một hàm thì hàm sẽ có chữ hoa.
Nó không có bất kỳ ý nghĩa nào, nó không có bất kỳ tác động nào đến mã.
Chỉ là để giúp nhau giúp dân gian ra ngoài để có thể phát hiện ra
rằng chức năng này cần một từ khóa mới.
Đó rõ ràng là điều cần được cải thiện.
Và đó là nơi giải pháp 4 xuất hiện.
Trước tiên, chúng tôi phải ủng hộ một trong những chức năng mà chúng tôi biết rằng nó yêu cầu mới
từ khóa chúng tôi đã làm việc.
Và đó là giải pháp 4 ra đời.
Đường cú pháp vải.
Nhưng nó là một đường cú pháp.
Điều đó có nghĩa là một cái gì đó thay đổi giao diện của nó, nhưng
không thay đổi nó dưới mui xe.
Đối với mục đích của chúng tôi, cho phần này ở đây, cách chúng tôi sẽ sử dụng nó ở đây,
nó không thay đổi bất cứ điều gì dưới mui xe.
Hai điều thúc đẩy điều này.
Nó xuất hiện vào năm 2015, ES6, Trong tuyên bố
người tạo chức năng của chúng tôi, khi được thực thi
tự động với các từ khóa mới giúp trả về một đối tượng thành user1.
Chạy lại nó sẽ trả về một đối tượng vào user2, có hai phần quan trọng đối với nó.
Có chức năng tạo đối tượng tự động.
Và sau đó là kho các chức năng được chia sẻ.
Tất cả chúng đều được đóng gói trên cùng một tổ hợp đối tượng chức năng.
Nhưng chúng tôi đã thông báo cho JavaScript hai phần riêng biệt.
Chúng tôi tuyên bố người tạo người dùng, tạo ra một chức năng và
một đối tượng có thuộc tính nguyên mẫu trên đó với một đối tượng đối với nó.
Mà chúng ta có thể lưu trữ toàn bộ, độc lập, các chức năng.
Trong các ngôn ngữ khác, hai thứ này có mối liên hệ mật thiết với nhau, phải không?
Nó có ý nghĩa, hàm này khi nó chạy sẽ tạo ra một đối tượng, trả về nó,
và đối tượng đó có quyền truy cập vào các chức năng này.
Vì vậy, họ giống như kết nối mật thiết.
Trong các ngôn ngữ khác bạn.
Ngay cả trong JavaScript, chúng được kết nối mật thiết và
chúng trên cùng một tổ hợp đối tượng chức năng.
Nhưng trong các ngôn ngữ khác, bạn có thể khai báo chúng cùng nhau.
Biết khai báo hàm who khi chạy trả về một đối tượng có quyền truy cập
được khai báo hoàn toàn riêng biệt.
Các hàm đi vào đối tượng nguyên mẫu được bán trên tài sản dự án,
xin lỗi rằng các đối tượng trên thuộc tính dự án, tất cả các đối tượng chức năng kết hợp.
Vì vậy, có, chúng được lưu trữ cùng nhau,
nhưng chúng không được khai báo có nghĩa là chúng ta không viết chúng vào JavaScript cùng nhau.
Chúng tôi không viết hướng dẫn các công việc để đạt được hai điều đó cùng nhau.
Chúng tôi không viết chúng cùng nhau, chúng tôi chạy riêng.
Một ngôn ngữ khác là chúng tôi thực hiện tất cả trong một cấu trúc, tất cả trong một lần,
tất cả trong một định dạng.
Và định dạng đó mọi người, bất cứ ai biết cấu trúc đó được gọi là gì
điều đó cho phép chúng ta làm những điều này cùng nhau, cứu những điều này cùng một lúc, Peter?
>> Adam: Một mệnh đề.
>> Will Sentance: Một mệnh đề chính xác.
Đó là mệnh đề rõ ràng, Peter.
>> Adam: Xin lỗi.
>> Will Sentance: Đó là một trò đùa, rõ ràng là trò đùa, một mệnh đề chính xác, chúng ta bắt đầu.
Nhưng Peter, anh tốt bụng đến mức bị chỉ ra là không.
Bạn thực sự là một người rất, rất tốt.
Không rõ ràng không giống như tôi, vì vậy chúng tôi đang viết tôi đã chia sẻ các phương pháp,
những phương pháp này được chia sẻ bởi tất cả những người khác.
Trên thực tế, chúng ta hãy tự giúp mình ở đây có một người dùng 701,
điều này sẽ lại xuất hiện từ việc chạy trình tạo người dùng,
hãy thực sự làm điều đó ở đây để đề phòng,
người dùng 701 với kết quả của một cuộc gọi khác tới Người tạo người dùng.
Hãy nói với Sarah và 19 tuổi và tất nhiên từ khóa mới ở phía trước và
mà sẽ được trả về người dùng 701.
Và lần này chúng ta hãy làm đúng, có đối tượng
với thuộc tính proto lên đến
đối tượng được chia sẻ và sau đó đặt tên, Sarah,
điểm 19.
Mọi người đều nhận được phần này ở đây, tôi hy vọng điều đó không ném mọi người.
Hai đối tượng đó, chúng đều có quyền truy cập vào các hàm, phương thức được chia sẻ này.
Chúng tôi đang lưu chúng trên cùng một tổ hợp chức năng, nhưng
chúng tôi đang khai báo chúng, >> Will Sentance: Riêng biệt.
Hãy làm tất cả ở một nơi.
Và cấu trúc lớp cho phép chúng ta làm điều đó.
Đây rồi, nó là dân gian theo cú pháp, tôi thực sự sẽ đi thẳng vào đây.
Đây là hai phần chúng ta đã làm trước đây, phải không?
Hãy nhớ rằng, chúng tôi đã tạo người dùng chức năng của chúng tôi,
tạo ra một tổ hợp đối tượng hàm.
Mặc dù khi nó chạy Sẽ tạo bên trong chính nó với một từ khóa mới,
một đối tượng lưu trữ user1 lần đầu tiên, lưu trữ user 701,
Lần thứ 701 mà mỗi người có quyền truy cập vào đối tượng này với đầy đủ các chức năng.
Người dùng tạo.prototype.increment.
Người dùng tạo.prototype.login.
Chúng tôi lưu chúng ở đó.
Bây giờ không có gì thay đổi dưới mui xe.
Chúng tôi chỉ cần thực hiện hai khai báo hoặc nhiệm vụ riêng biệt này
trong một cấu trúc, chúng tôi gọi nó là một lớp.
Chúng tôi lấy nhãn của hàm và chúng tôi làm cho bạn nhãn của lớp.
Ngay sau khi bạn khai báo một lớp, chúng tôi nghĩ chúng tôi nhận được những người như thế nào?
>> Will Sentance: Dan? >> Dan: Một đối tượng.
>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi nhận được một tổ hợp đối tượng hàm.
>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi nhận được một đối tượng, vâng.
Chúng ta có được một đối tượng sẵn sàng để nhận một hàm và một đối tượng.
Ngay sau khi chúng tôi làm điều đó, chúng tôi sẽ xử lý phần đầu tiên bên trong nó.
Vì vậy, ngay sau khi chúng ta khai báo nó, chúng ta sẽ nhận được một tổ hợp đối tượng chức năng.
Nếu không, chúng ta có một tổ hợp đối tượng chức năng.
Và bit đầu tiên của tổ hợp đối tượng hàm, chúng tôi cung cấp hàm tạo phụ đề,
và đó là bit hàm, hoặc tổ hợp đối tượng hàm ở đó.
Chúng tôi không biết.
Chúng tôi cung cấp cho nó một phụ đề, hàm tạo.
>> Will Sentance: Và tất nhiên nó nằm trên nó trong tổ hợp đối tượng hàm trong
bit đối tượng, một thuộc tính nguyên mẫu, là một đối tượng có đầy đủ chức năng,
cũng chưa, chúng tôi lưu trữ ngay lập tức những gì, và
chúng tôi không còn phải chỉ định chúng theo cách thủ công mà chúng tôi chỉ cần liệt kê chúng ra.
Thậm chí không có dấu phẩy ở giữa, chúng tôi chỉ liệt kê chúng ra.
Chúng tôi có thể liệt kê bao nhiêu tùy thích và tất cả chúng sẽ được lấy từng cái một và
đằng sau những gì JavaScript đang chạy?
Nó nói rằng người dùng create.prototype.increment và
nó dính chúng vào đối tượng đó.
Mọi người, không có gì thay đổi dưới mui xe ở đây.
Chúng ta có ngay khi chúng ta khai báo một lớp trước khi chúng ta thực hiện nó bằng cách khai báo một hàm.
Đã ngầm tạo một đối tượng gắn liền với nó một tổ hợp đối tượng hàm
trong đó có một thuộc tính nguyên mẫu là chính một đối tượng.
Chúng tôi đã lưu trữ các chức năng được chia sẻ của mình vào đó.
Bây giờ, chúng ta tạo một mệnh đề là một tổ hợp đối tượng hàm.
Và phần đầu tiên của nó, chúng tôi đưa ra một hàm tạo phụ đề và
bạn có thể thấy nó giống hệt nhau.
Điều đầu tiên mà chúng tôi chuyển vào hàm tạo khác này trước tiên trong đường dẫn của bạn, xin lỗi.
Điều đầu tiên chúng tôi lưu trữ trong đó.
Và tạo cho chúng ta một hàm tạo là bit hàm của tổ hợp đối tượng hàm.
Và sau đó tất cả các chức năng chúng tôi liệt kê bên dưới,
chúng tôi chỉ sẽ liệt kê chúng theo nghĩa đen.
Ở hậu trường, George, chúng tôi đang xem phần đầu tiên và
chúng ta đang đi lên, tắt chúng ta đi đến tổ hợp đối tượng hàm của chúng ta là lớp.
Và nhìn vào bit đối tượng của nó và xem xét thuộc tính nguyên mẫu của nó và
nhìn vào đối tượng và phương thức câu chuyện đó, được gọi là tăng dần.
Và sau đó, slide tiếp theo sẽ đăng nhập.
Tắt chúng ta đến lớp người tạo người dùng,
mà thực sự chỉ là một tổ hợp đối tượng hàm và xem xét thuộc tính nguyên mẫu.
Chúng tôi chèn một thuộc tính đăng nhập vào nó và gán một chức năng.
Và sau đó cũng vậy.
Khi chúng tôi chạy tạo người dùng, tôi đã viết hoa ở đây không thay đổi.
Khi chúng tôi chạy trình tạo người dùng với từ khóa biết chúng tôi sẽ chạy hàm nào
đối tượng kết hợp, Dan?
Khi chúng tôi chạy trình tạo người dùng bằng số chín với từ khóa mới phía trước,
chúng ta chạy bit nào của tổ hợp đối tượng hàm.
>> Dan: Người xây dựng.
>> Will Sentance: Hàm, vâng chúng ta gọi nó là hàm tạo nhưng
nó thực sự chỉ có cùng một chức năng, yeah.
Và khi out trả về một đối tượng,
nó sẽ liên kết đến bit nào của tổ hợp đối tượng chức năng Dan?
>> Dan: Nguyên mẫu.
>> Will Sentance: Đối tượng nguyên mẫu chính xác, không có gì thay đổi.
Nhưng nó trông giống nhiều ngôn ngữ khác hơn.
Nhưng điều đó đối với tôi, tôi thậm chí không biết,
bởi vì nó đang làm những gì mà các ngôn ngữ khác đang làm?
Không, chắc chắn là không.
Và gần như nhiều hơn nữa, tôi không biết, nó lại làm cho nó dễ đọc hơn.
Nó làm cho nó rõ ràng dễ đọc hơn.
Nhưng đằng sau hậu trường, không có gì thay đổi.
Có nghĩa là nếu chúng ta thực sự muốn hiểu và gỡ lỗi và
sử dụng những kỹ thuật này, nó thậm chí còn thích hợp hơn
mà bây giờ chúng tôi hiểu những gì đang diễn ra.
Đang tiếp tục bởi vì thậm chí bây giờ nó trông giống các ngôn ngữ khác.
Ý nghĩa sẽ mang lại cho tất cả các quan điểm của chúng tôi về cách các ngôn ngữ khác triển khai
những tính năng này, nhưng không hoạt động trong hậu trường cuộc sống thực.
Nhân tiện, nó chính xác là cùng một mô hình, như chúng ta đã thấy ở phần trước và giải pháp 2.
Nó chỉ được bao bọc bởi tự động hóa chìa khóa mới,
đó là rất nhiều mã đã được tự động hóa bởi từ khóa mới.
Và bây giờ đã hoàn tất việc thiết lập điểm bắt đầu của chức năng
mà khi chạy trả về các đối tượng.
Và các đối tượng bị mất hành động có quyền truy cập vào các chia sẻ hoặc chức năng ở đó bây giờ,
bây giờ chúng ta thông qua quá trình thiết lập điều này trong một lần Trong các cấu trúc lớp,
trong thiết lập lớp.
Nhưng nó không thay đổi bất cứ điều gì, nó chỉ khiến chúng ta viết ít mã hơn.
Nó được gọi là đường cú pháp, làm cho nó trông đẹp hơn,
Tôi cho rằng nó giống như đóng băng đường trên một chiếc bánh, tôi không biết.
Về mặt tổng hợp, bạn thích, làm cho nó trông đẹp hơn, nhưng
nó sẽ không thay đổi bất cứ điều gì dưới mui xe.
Tất cả đúng dân gian, lợi ích nổi lên như một tiêu chuẩn mới không còn nghi ngờ gì nữa
cảm thấy giống như sự khởi đầu của các ngôn ngữ khác Python và Java.
Nó trông rất giống phong cách của các ngôn ngữ, ngôn ngữ, vấn đề khác.
Tôi nói 95 cho giải pháp 3, 99% nhà phát triển không biết nó hoạt động như thế nào.
Một lần nữa, tại sao các cuộc phỏng vấn thất bại?
Tôi không biết đây là một nhưng
không thể giải quyết các vấn đề mà họ muốn giải quyết theo cách họ muốn giải quyết chúng.
Nhưng bạn sẽ không phải là một trong những người đó.